حياكم الله جدد زعيم التيار الصدري مقتدى
الصدر مطالبته رئيس الوزراء العراقي نور
المالكي بكشف المفسدين وقمع الميليشيات
كما شكرها وايضا على زياره بعض المناطق
المتاثره بالتفجيرات في بغداد ياتي ذلك
بعد يومين من اتهام الصدر للمالكي للسعي
لاشعال حرب طائفيه في العراق نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
الى اي حد مثلت تصريحات الصدر الاخيره
تراجعا عن اتهاماته السابقه للمالك باثاره
الحرب الطائفيه
وما هو مستقبل العلاقه بين الصدر والملك
في ضوء مواقف التيار الصدري الاخيره من
حكومه الملك
اذا من الانذار الصارم شديد اللهجه انتقل
زعيم التيار الصدري خلال يومين فقط الى
شكر رئيس الحكومه العراقيه موضوع الانذار
والشكر هو ذاته سياسه نور المالكي خاصه
فيما يتعلق بادائه تجاه سلسله التفشيرات
وحللت الاضطراب الامنيه الاخيره في العراق
وما بين الشكر والانذار بدا الصدر متمسكا
بمطلبين اساسيين وان اختلف اسلوب تقديمهما
قمع الميليشيات وكشف المفسدين
جارحه كانت انتقادات مقتدى الصدر السابقه
للمالكي فرئيس الوزراء العراقي بحسبها
يدفع البلاد الى حرب طائفيه والشعب
بمكوناته كافه اصبح في مواجهه الارهاب بلا
حكومه تحمي اضافه الى تقصيره في ملف
الفساد ولقد اعذر من انذر هذا ما قالته
بيانات سابقه للصدر عرفت بسقوفها العاليه
لكنه في بيانه الاخيره غدا اقل حده شكر
المالكي على زيارته لما سماها بالمناطق
المنكوبه في بغداد اعتبرها عملا شجاعا
يعطي انطباعا بان الحكومه لا تسكن خلف جدر
تركه الشعب بلا معين ابقى الصدر اذا على
انتقاداته للرجل لكنه حولها الى مطالب
فبعد ان وصفه سابقا بانه اما مقصر او قاصر
في محاربه الفساد والطائفيه خالطت الرقه
مطالبه الاخيره فعل الملك كما قال محو
الطائفيه وزياره المعتصمين لانه ابو لهم
وهم رعيته على حد وصف بي انه الاخير مع
ابقاء الصدر على مطالبته للمالك بقمع
الميليشيات وكشف المفسدين
بدوره داب المالكي على نفي ما ياخذه عليهم
وعرضوه ومن بينهم الصدر وغيره اكثر من
الظهور التقى شيوخ عشائر زارا مؤسسات
امنيه واكد رفضه للطائفيه متهما للاخرين
بها واكد انه وجه حكومته لاتخاذ اجراءات
عاجله لملاحقه الميليشيات التي وصفها
بالعصابات على ان وقائع الشهرين الاخيرين
تحديدا تثير المخاوف اكثر مما تبعث على
الطمانينه كما يقول معرض المالكي الاخرون
خلالهما قتل اكثر من 1100 عراقي وخللهما
اصبحت التفجيرات حدثا يوميا ما دفع هؤلاء
الى اتهامه بدفع البلاد للحرب الاهليه
وتزامن هذا مع ظهور ميليشيات تقوم بعمليات
خطف وقتل على الهويه الطائفيه يتهم الملك
من قبل مناوئيه برعايتها ودعمها وتوجيهها
سرا ضد خصومه وانكارها والتنديد بها كل ما
وجهت اليه اصابع الاتهام في العالم
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بغداد
الدكتور ضياء الاسدي الامين العام لكتله
الاحرار الممثل السياسي للخط الصدري من
بيروت معنى عزه شهبندر عضو مجلس النواب
العراقي عن ائتلاف دوله القانون ومن عمان
الدكتور حيدر سعيد مستشار المركز العراقي
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه وابدا معك دكتور
ضياء الاسدي
دكتور بصراحه نريد ان نفهم ماذا يقول
الصدر تحديدا ماذا يقول اليوم مقارنه بما
قاله قبل يومين فقط
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لكم ولضيفيكم
الكريمين ولمشاهديكم الكرام ما يريد ان
يقدمه سماحه السيد مقتدى الصدر هو نفس
المبدا الذي تحدثنا عنه كثيرا وهو اننا
مشاركون في هذه الحكومه
ولكننا ننتقدها اذا كان هناك تقصير ونقف
لمعارضه الاداء اذا كان الاداء سيئا او
كان هناك تقصير في الاداء قبل يوم او
يومين اصدر سماحه السيد مقتدى الصدر
البيان يندد فيه بالاعمال الاجراميه التي
طالت حياه العراقيين كذلك دعا الحكومه الى
اخذ مسؤولياتها والى محاسبه المقصرين ودعا
الى جلسه طارئه للبرلمان العراقي لاستضافه
السيد رئيس مجلس الوزراء والجهات الامنيه
المقصره
على الرغم من ان ذلك لم يحصل لكننا بقينا
متمسكين بخيار ان مجلس النواب هو بيت
الشعب وبيت الشعب يجب ان يحضر لرئيس
الحكومه رئيس السلطه التنفيذيه حتى يعرف
الناس من هو المقصر
بعد هذه الاعمال الاجراميه التي طالت حياه
الناس كانت هناك خطوات من اجل التصحيح
احداها كانت اقاله بعض القيادات الامنيه
او استبدالها والخطوه التي نراها اليوم
وهي زياره المناطق التي تعرضت الى هجمات
عنف وهجمات تفجير فما كان من سماحه السيد
مقتدى الصدر الا ان يتوجه بالشكر على هذه
الخطوه على هذا الموقف هو الذي
اسمح لي ساستوقفك قليلا يعني
لازلت بصراحه يعني غير مقتنع تماما
وساعدني ان افهم لان ما اريده ان افهم هذا
النقطه تحديدا يعني الفتره الاخيره كانت
لهجه الانتقادات شديده جدا يعني وصلت الى
حد الانذار الصارم والاخير
مجرد زياره تقلب الامور هكذا يعني ما الذي
تغير على الارض
ليستوجب يعني ما نشعر وكانه لهجه جديده
ساعدني ان افهم
ابدا لم لم نتغير ولم يتغير موقفنا ما
زلنا ننتقد الحكومه وما زلنا نؤشر على
ملفات تقصير هذه الحكومه كل ما في الامر
ان هناك موقف صدر من رئيس الوزراء استحق
عليه الشكر لكن هناك مواقف اخرى ينبغي
عليه العمل على تحقيقها اول موقف او اول
خطوه يسعى او نسعى جميعا الى حث السيد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الى معالجتها ومعالجه
من الحكومه اذا سمحت فقط
كل موقف برايك استدعي موقف مستقل ومنفصل
تماما من التيار الصدري يعني هذا ما ربما
يخلق حاله من الارباك بعض الشيء
الا توافق ليس هناك ارباك ابدا ليس هناك
ارباك نحن نريد ان نوضح ان مواقف الشركاء
في العمل السياسي يجب ان تكون مواقف واعيه
ومواقف موضوعيه هناك بعض المواقف لدى
الحكومه بعض المعالجات يجب ان نؤشر عليها
بالنقد وهناك معالجات اخرى يجب ان تشكر
عليها الحكومه فاذا عملت الحكومه عملا
حسنا او جيدا استحقت عليه الشكر اما
الملفات التي تقصر به او تقصر الحكومه في
ادائها فينبغي ان تنتقد الحكومه حتى يعرف
المواطن ان هذه الحكومه هناك ما يجب ان
تفعله لتحسن ادائها وتحسن صورتها امام
الناس ولذلك سماحه السيد ينطلق من منطلق
المواقف هو لا ياخذ هذه الحكومه بالجمله
ويقول ان هذه الحكومه سيئه ويجب على
الحكومه ان ان تزاح او تزال هو يقول وضحت
الفكره انتقل للسيد عزت الشهابندر يعني
سمعت ما قيل انتم كيف تنظرون الى هذه
التصريحات المت غيره والمختلفه تماما في
ظرف يومين فقط
شكرا لك تحياتي لضيوفك الكرام في الحقيقه
احنا ايضا
يعني
هناك استغراب لهذا التغير بالمواقف كما
تفضلتي ان من يتهم
بالتحريض على حرب طائفيه ومن يتهم بحمايه
المفسدين لا يشفع له ان يقوم بزيارتين
فيشكر
ولذلك انا ما اعتقده واتمناه ان هناك تحول
في فهم الواقع
السياسي والامني
الذي يجري في العراق الان
وهناك موقف ايجابي من قبل سماحه السيد
الصدر تجاه الحكومه
وما تعانيه الحكومه الان من ازمات يصعب
عليها بمفردها من دون حلفائها ان تتجاوز
هذا التحدي وهذا القلق الذي ينتاب واقعنا
السياسي
والامنيه هو ليس
توزيع بالمفرق للمواقف كما ذكر الاخ
الاسدي
لان لا يجوز يعني ان يشكر من يتهم
بالتحريض على حرب طائفيه او باليتهم
بحمايه الفاسدين والمفسدين واليوم على
زيارتين احنا نشكره هذا لا يمكن ان
ما هو تفسير
تفسير الذي اتمناه قد لا اجزم عليه تفسيري
ان السيد مقتدى الصدر
وضحت لديه الصوره ان هناك تحدي كبير يتحدى
التجربه السياسيه برمتها ان هناك تحدي
يتحدى الواقع السياسي الجديد برمته يجب ان
يغض النظر فيه عن العديد من التفاصيل ونقف
مع الحكومه خاصه امام الملف
الامني الذي يمكن ان يؤذي في حياه الناس
بهذه الطريقه
لنفترض ان هذا حسن ايضا يصعب ان نتخيل ان
يحصل هذا خلال يومين يعني اريد ان اسالك
انت ما تفسيرك ماذا ترى وراء هذا التحول
والمواقف المتباينه للتيار الصدري
شكرا
يعني انا اولا اتحافظ على كلمه تحول يعني
انا لا اعتقد ان هناك تحول في موقف التيار
الصدري بس
اذا نحاول نفهم الشكر اللي بدا البعض ان
هناك تحول في موقف التيار من سياسه
الماريكان خليني بس اقول انه هناك
نبدا من نقطه اخرى اذا تفضل هناك هناك
هناك ثلاثه طيارات
التيار المالكي والتيار المعارض بشكل كامل
الذي ذهب الى مشروع سحب الثقه وتحالف مع
السنه والكرد من اجل هذا المشروع وهو
التيار الصدري والتيار الوسطي التيار الذي
ايضا هو يعارض المالكي ويتحفظ على سياسات
المالكي ولكن يطمح الى ان يكون التغيير من
داخل البيت الشيعي التيار الصدري بالتاكيد
في تصوري
يحاول احيانا ان يقترب من هذا التيار
الوسطي بمعنى يحاول ان يقدم سياسات
براغماتيه تجاه المالكي ولا سيما انه
التياران الوسطي والتيار المعارض يعني
يخليني اسميه اقصى اليمين اذا صح التعبير
هو يريد ان يحيد المالكي خلال السنه
المتبقيه لولايته الثانيه يعني اذا كان
هذان التياران يتفقان في تصوري وربما
لمعلومات خاصه انهما لا يريدان الطيران
الوسطي الذي يضم المجلس الاعلى والتيارات
شيعيه اخرى والتيار الصدري لا المالكي ان
يبقى لولايه ثالثه لرئاسه الوزراء فالمهم
هو تحيد المالكي خلال السنه المتبقيه
لماذا اولا لان هذين التيارين يعتقدان بان
المالكي احيانا يقدم مبادرات او غير
محسوبه خلينا نتحدث بهذا التعبير فتحيد
المالكي خلال هذا السنه امر مهم الشيء
الثاني في تصوري انه الان الوضع في العراق
وصل الى مرحله خطيره جدا خلال الاسبوعين
الاخيرين بدات بعض البوادر التي حدثت في
من الشات من كل الطائفتين تتقاتل سياراتهم
فقهه وعباد استهداف للمدنيين على اساس
في تصوري
انا اتصور بموقف التيار موقف السيد مقتدى
الصدر الاخير هو محاوله يعني الدعم او
استكشاف الى اي مدى ممكن ان يطلق المالكي
مبادره لوضع حد للعنف الاهلي الذي تفجر
بالتاكيد المالكي هو اكثر شخص ممكن ان
يطلق مبادره بعد الارتجاع لذلك غير قضيه
الشكر هو تحدث بشكل واضح على قضيه ايقاف
الميليشيات التي هو قال انه يرعاها او
تمارس نشاطها هي نقطه التحول فعلا هل
محاوله تحييد
سنناقش اذا سمحتم لنا بعد الفاصل مستقبل
علاقه الصدرين بالمالكي في ضوء هذه
المواقف الاخيره نرجو ان تبقى معنا
من جديد الى هذه الحلقه التي نتناول فيها
دعوات الصدر المالكي لكشف المفسدين ولجم
الميليشيات واعود اليك دكتور ضياء الاسدي
استمعت الى ما قيل عن محاوله التحييد وهل
ربما ليس هناك اي تحول حقيقي ولكن يعني
حتى نتحدث عن المستقبل لابد ان نقف عند
نقطه معينه هي في الواقع يعني نقطه لافته
الانذار الذي قدمه الصدر فقط قبل يومين
للحكومه والشعب هذه علامه استفهام كبيره
عليها يعني ما الذي كان يعني هل يترتب
عليها خطوه لاحقه
وهي يعني خطيره
ما الذي كان يريد ان يقول ما الذي يهدد به
تحديدا يعني الطرفين
سيده الكلمه اريد ان اوضح شيء يبدو انه
خافي يعني على الكثيرين سمعت سيد مقتدى
الصدر لم يوجه الشكر للمره الاولى الى
السيد المالكي كان هناك شكر سابق في يعني
في منتصف ازمه سحب الثقه من الحكومه يعني
كان في الوقت الذي يعمل فيه الخط الصدري
على سحب الثقه من الحكومه كانت هناك كلمه
شكر وجهت على احد مواقف رئيس الوزراء
القضيه بالنسبه لنا ليست بالمفرق كما قال
السيد عزت شابندر نحن
ندرك ان هناك وعيا سياسيا اعمق من هذا هذه
التوصيفات البسيطه السطحيه اعتقد انها لا
تفي بالغرض نحن نؤمن بالمواقف ولا نؤمن
بالمسميات ولا نؤمن بالشخصيات ولا نؤمن
حتى في هذه المرحله بمسميات الاحزاب نؤمن
بالبرنامج وبالموقف اذا كان هناك برنامج
الان لدى السيد رئيس مجلس الوزراء لاصلاح
الحال وهذه البادره الان في زياره مواقع
التفجيرات في تغيير
القيادات الامنيه هذه بادره الان هذه
بادره استجابه عن البرنامج والبا اذا سمحت
لي يعني بصراحه دكتور ضياء انت هنا عندما
تقول ان
مقتدى الصدر عندما تصل الامور الى نقطه
حرجه ياخذ خطوه الى الوراء يعني ويبدو ان
الامور تاخذ منحه اخر قلت ليست المره
الاولى هذا اسمح ليعزز الفكره الموجوده
عند البعض ان العمليه كلها تقاسم ادوار
وان الصدر لو اراد فعلا ان يحدث هذا
التغيير لهدد بالانسحاب يعني مجرد التهديد
كان ربما كافيا لاحداث التغيير او شيء من
التغيير ولكنه يلجا الى الكلام والتهديدات
والانتقادات وهذا كله يعوم العمليه
ما ردك لا ابدا هناك مطالب اخرى في البيان
علينا ان لا ننسى يعني نعلق او نركز على
كلمه الشكر وننسى المطالب الاخرى المطالب
التي تتعلق بزياره المتظاهرين بزياره
ساحات الاعتصام بتولي ملف الفساد وهو
الملف الذي ينخر في جسد الدوله العراقيه
هناك يعني مسؤوليه كبيره مسؤوليه تقع على
عاتق الجهات الامنيه من اجل الحرص او
العمل على استقرار العراق ثم التوجه الى
التنميه يعني محاربه الفساد هو بمعناه
اننا على ينبغي على الحكومه ان تتوجه الى
ملف التنميه ومعالجه المشكلات الاداريه
الحقيقيه التي تشل حركه الدوله العراقيه
معالجه الميليشيات هو معناه التركيز على
الملف الامني واستقرار العراق كلمه الشكر
هي مجرد موقف واما ما جاء في البيان
فاعتقد ان فيه من الاهميه الشيء الكثير
الذي يحتم على السيد المالكي ان ينتبه في
المرحله المقبله الى معالجه المشكلات التي
تعاني منها الحكومه
السيد شهبندر
ما الذي يمكن ان تقدمه حكومه المالكي
استجابه لهذه المطالب التي تتكرر كما قال
السيد الاسدي يجب ان لا نتوقف عند الامور
السطحيه كما عبر عنها
يعني نحن ننضم الى دعوه السيد مقتدى الصدر
الى الاخ رئيس الوزراء ان يكشف الفاسدين
ويضرب بيد من حديد عليهم ويحارب
الميليشيات من اي طائفه
كانت هذه الميليشيا ولا يسهل لهم اعمالهم
هذا كلنا ننضم الى هذه الدعوه والسيد رئيس
الوزراء ايضا هو منتبه
لذلك
يهمني ان اميز بين خطاب للسيد مقتدى
كمنافس
لشريكه في اداره السلطه
ومره اخرى خطاب ينطلق به من شريك حقيقي في
هذه التجربه السياسيه ولذلك ما يصدر من
نقد في كثير من الاحيان وقد يكون حادا
ومبالغا فيه
للاخ رئيس الوزراء انما ينطلق فيه من انه
منافس داخل
ساحه واحده مع السيد رئيس الوزراء ولكن
مره اخرى انا هكذا افهم في الحقيقه لم
يسعفني الاغذيه الاسدي في تفسير اقتنع به
ومره اخرى يقف السيد مقتدى الصدر امام
المصلحه
نقل الان عن الدكتور اياد علاوي طالب سيد
المالك بالاستقاله لتجنيب البلاد المزيد
من العنف
ما هو تعليقكم
والله هناك بعض
المناشدات يعني اذا حضرت لا تعد واذا غابت
لا تفتقد الاخ اياد علاوي الان يغرد خارج
السرب وهو نقطه خارج المعادله تماما
ولا يشكل شيء وقد حاول مرارا ان
يكون له حضوره في ظل هذا الحراك السياسي
الشديد والحساس في الوقت
الحاضر الان القائمه العراقيه
تتحرك بلا زعيم فهو ما هو عنوانه الان في
ان يطلب من المالكي ان يستقيل او لا
يستقيل وعليه في الحقيقه هذه مساله لا
تستحق التوقف عندها كثيرا ولكن ربما ما
يستحق التوقف عند الدكتور حيدر هو موضوع
حلقتنا الان مستقبل العلاقه بين الصدريين
والحكومه العراقيه على راسها المالكي كيف
ترى هذه العلاقه على خلفيه التصريحات التي
استمعنا اليها
يعني انا اتصور فيما يخص الصدريين يعني
انا شخصيا
يعني استبعد ان يكون هناك تحول في الموقف
تجاه
رئيس الوزراء هناك نعم يعني الصدريون مضوا
في مشروع سحب الثقه لكن في لحظه معه عندما
عبئ الشارع طائفيه وعندما لم يستطع هذا
المشروع ان يمضي الى نهايته لاي سبب كان
انا في تصورهم وضعوا هذه الحسابات امامهم
كذلك في تصوري ان الصدريين الان يقراون
الوضع في العراق من خلال الخريطه
الاقليميه الاوسع
موضوع ايران وكذلك موضوع سوريا
اي تغيير في
سده الحكم او في رئيس الوزراء انا في
تصوري سيكون مقروءا من خلال الخريطه
الاقليميه لكن
يعني انا اتصور الان الرهان داخل التيار
الصدري او داخل القوه الشيعيه الرئيسيه هو
على الانتخابات النيابيه المقبله
الانتخابات النيابيه المقبله هي ربما يعني
الافق الاول
لتغيير الوضع في العراق
النتيجه التي ستاتي بها الانتخابات واذا
كان هناك اجماع شيعي
وتوافق اقليمي على ان لا يبقى نور المالكي
رئيسا للوزراء لولايه ثالثه انا اعتقد هذا
المدخل الذي سيعدل الازمه التي يمر بها
نظام الحكم بمعنى انه خروج المالكي
سيتيح صفقه جديده بين الفرقاء العراقيين
المواضع والمساحات التي مكنت المالكيه او
السلطه التنفيذيه من التغول بهذا الشكل من
السيطره على المؤسسه العسكريه بهذا الشكل
من ضرب
الفصل بين السلطات او السيطره على
المؤسسات السياسيه العراقيه جميعا الصفقه
السياسيه الطائره
الاسدي كيف ترى دور الاقليمي في العلاقه
في المستقبل بين الطرفين وربما نتحدث
تحديدا عن دور ايران
هناك نقطه مهمه سته ليلى هو ان التيار
الصدري لا يؤسس برنامجه سياسي على شخصيات
يعني العلاقه صحيح مع كل الاطراف السياسيه
العامله او الفاعله في المشهد السياسي
العراقي مهمه بالنسبه لنا لكننا لا نبني
مشروعنا على شخصيه او على حزب او كيان
سياسي نبني مشروعنا على اساس الواقع اما
من ناحيه تاثير القوى الاقليميه على على
طرف سياسي معين يعني ليس بالضروره ان يكون
السيد المالكي على اي طرف اخر فنحن نؤمن
بان الشراكه مع الاحزاب والكتل والشخصيات
التي تمتلك مشروعا وطنيا هي الابقى وهي
الاكثر حفاظا على مستقبل العراق واستقرار
العراق لذلك نريد ان نخلق حاله من
الانسجام مع الكتل السياسيه التي تستمد
مشروعها من مصلحه العراق وليس من مصالح
دول الجوار او من تاثيرات دول الجوار
فعلاقتنا مع السيد المالكي مرهونه بما
سيكون عليه برنامج السيد المالكي ما يكون
عليه رؤيه السيد المالكي او حزبه او او من
ياتلف معه في المرحله المقبله لذلك نستطيع
في ذلك الوقت ان نؤسس رؤيتنا بما هو موجود
على الارض وليس ما موجود حاليا ولكنكم
انتم طلبتم مرارا بتغيير المالكي شخصيا
يعني سمعنا مقالته قبل ايام فقط باختصار
شديد لو سمحت لم يبقى الا اقل من دقيقه
ولذلك نقول اننا لا نؤسس علاقاتنا على شخص
نحن طالبنا بتغييره لانه كان اداء اداء
فاشل في نظرنا اداء الدوره او دوره في
اداره الحكومه كان هناك فشل كبير في اداره
مؤسسات الدوله اشكرك دكتور ضياء الاسدي
الامين العام لكتله الاحرار التي تعتبر
الممثل السياسي للخط الصدري شكرا لسيد عزت
الشمندر عضو مجلس النواب العراقي يعني
ائتلاف دوله القانون وشكرا لي يا دكتور
حيدر سعيد مستشار المركز العراقي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه من عمان وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
مورا الخبر